new weekly jobless numbers showing 840
000 americans applied for
unemployment benefits last week alone
white house economic adviser larry
kudlow joins us now larry good morning
to you
always appreciate your time what does
this
number tell you about how this economic
recovery
is going because that's still that
number hovers at a historic
high for this country and as of this
morning
29 weeks since the coronavirus lockdowns
began
the number totals 63 million
that works out to 40 percent of the us
labor force
i mean this is a lot of americans still
hurting as a result of this pandemic
uh i i don't deny that that a lot of
americans are still hurting i think
there's still a lot of hardship out
there
but but i do want to note these weekly
unemployment claims have fallen
sharply from the peaks registered in uh
mid to late april early may they've been
trending lower now for five months i
also want to add to that sandra
uh continuing claims which is the actual
payments not the applications but the
payments
fell sharply by over one million
and that number is usually a pretty good
forecaster
of the next month's uh job so
uh i i think the labor situation
is looking much better we're moving in
the right direction
i might add two-thirds of the returning
jobs
come from the lower wage end so we're
prospering
there it's a tough battle it's not going
to be done
just in five months after the terrible
pandemic
contraction and all that went with it
but the reality is the economy is in the
right direction it still looks to me
very much like a v-shaped recovery
you're going to have a huge number
for q3 gdp uh we've been saying 20
plus you got a lot of people atlanta fed
and others
uh goldman sachs saying 35 housing boom
autos boom retailing boom
manufacturing boom going on to uh
restock inventories
when you look at the whole plan panoply
these numbers
you see a pretty strong self-sustaining
recovery
i still think we should have some of the
targeted assistance packages that
president trump
and steve mnuchin are talking about we
can get to that in a second
but i think the economy is in very good
footing
and really recovering faster than almost
anybody thought and let's not forget
even the federal reserve
has upped its economic growth forecast
for the second half of this year and
early next year and i do want to point
out to your point
the new claims are the lowest although
still very high the lowest since march
14th
the continuing claims you point out
another important number
almost 11 million but still the lowest
since march 28th larry
the president just joined maria
bartiromo on fox business he was asked
why he ended those stimulus talks
knowing so many people still need help
including american businesses here was
his response
shutdown talks two days ago because they
weren't working out
now they are starting to work out it
wasn't our workers fault it wasn't our
airline's fault that china did this
so larry you're advising the president
you see what's happening in the economy
can you
tell the american people that something
gets done before election day does it
well i'd like to i mean i don't think
the recovery itself
depends on a so-called assistance
package
however importantly we have made
targeted pleas for assistance in key
areas
and now the president believes we should
shift
into a uh you know stand-alone
bills to get the key points through the
big package had
way too much spending for state and
local bailouts i
ended the hyde amendment federal funding
for abortion
additional health care for illegal
immigrants there's a whole bunch of
things in there
that had nothing really to do with covet
or economic recovery now
we have been asking secretary mnuchin is
doing a great job of difficult
negotiations
we would like to see some unemployment
assistance
we had an executive order but that's not
going to last forever we need congress
for unemployment assistance
we'd like to extend the ppp small
business loans there's
money left over 135 billion
let's use it the president has signed
off
on the assistance checks that would be
direct mail but we need legislation
to do that we also want to help the kids
get back to school make the schools as
safe as possible
now those are just vital targeted
assistance areas that would strengthen
the economy
deal with covet and help those you know
you mentioned before correctly
see there's a lot of folks unemployed
there's a lot of hardships this is an
important issue the one that we just
helped them in a targeted way and i've
got limited time larry i'm sorry
we'd like to see this hash out on the
debate stage the president just said
virtual no thank you he doesn't want to
debate uh joe biden virtually
do you think the president should still
do the debate even though it's now been
announced it's virtual
well i think you're going to see a
renegotiation of that
i think the president is getting well uh
he will pass the test he will be showing
negative
uh testing so i i'm not sure that's
going to happen
but i do want to say sandra it's so
important to me
mike pence vice president mike pence
showed last night in the debate which he
won
going away in a calm manner
he took command of the debate
and crucially time and again
pointed out the key differences between
biden harris
and trump pence on taxes
on regulations on energy on
socializing nationalizing health care on
tough on china
and good trade deals and of course right
to life
and stacking the supreme court he made
this
so clear differences matter okay
you've got a very extremist left-wing
democratic candidates and you've got a
good mainstream conservative candidates
who by the way increased living
standards by five times as much
it sounds like you weren't the president
people did it in eight years
all right i'm totally out of time i do i
got it
and i want him i want him my message and
i want him to show
the differences between the two teams as
mike pence did
brilliantly yesterday and by the way
mike pence
looked like a president to me
larry kudlow thank you